I would rather have a conversation.
I would rather spend time, you know,
acquiring information, listening to
interesting podcasts and then talk about
what I've been listening to and reading.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
and today I want to talk about
task-based language learning.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
Uh, if you follow me on a podcast
service, uh, please leave a review.
I do appreciate it.
So task-based language learning.
The really, the reason I raise this
subject is because I realized just
how important it is in language
learning to have specific tasks.
Um, I noticed this, that if I
assign myself a task or if I feel
an obligation to do something, or if
someone assigns a task to me, then
I'm likely to do it simply because
it's, it's easy to have a task.
If my wife says, you know,
chop these vegetables.
Okay, chop the vegetables.
It's, it helps it's, you don't have to
kind of think what should I be doing now?
You have a task, and the
same with language learning.
So first thing in the morning, uh,
typically I'll listen to a podcast
and then I'll try and grab the URL if
it's on YouTube and somehow get an MP3
file so that I can get it transcribed.
So now I've got this task that's
developing, I'm listening to this podcast.
I'm, I've got the transcript.
I'm studying a transcript onLingQ
without even having to think about it.
I have this task that I have to do.
Um, if my tutor worked to
assign me a task, here are three
lessons I want you to read them.
I want you to save words and phrases or,
uh, when we're on our 90-Day Challenge,
I'm trying to keep to a certain level in
terms of LingQs created are words known.
These are very specific things over
and above my general interest in the
language, specific tasks that help
get me going and like so much in life,
life it's important to get going.
It's important to do something.
If you do something, it
leads to other things.
So tasks I think are very important
to keep us, you know, going forward
in our language learning activities.
But when you say task-based language
learning, if you Google for it,
you'll find a different definition.
And that task-based language instruction
is a method of language instruction, where
as I understand it, um, the learner is
asked to perform a task in the language,
uh, not to worry about grammar structures
or vocabulary and to incorporate, you
know, hand gestures or whatever in order
to accomplish a task in the language.
Now, I, I don't know whether this is an
effective way of teaching the language.
To me, it's a little artificial.
Uh, it's a bit like this
role playing thing, which I
also don't particularly like.
I would rather have a conversation.
I would rather spend time, you know,
acquiring information, listening to
interesting podcasts, and then talk
about what I've been listening to
and reading and sort of gradually
see my vocabulary increase, my
comprehension  level increase.
I'm not that interested in, in engaging
in these artificial activities.
The, uh, one example of the application
of this task-based language instruction,
and of course in the field of
language instruction there are all
kinds of, you know, the latest, you
know, fad, uh, as I see it, uh...
I'm with Krashen, I think language
instruction comes down to comprehensible,
compelling input, massive listening and
reading, allowing the brain to get used
to the language and everything else is
kind of refinements, which are either
interesting or not very interesting,
but maybe not all that necessary.
One application is in Canada we
have a thing called the 12 language
benchmarks, which again yet another way
of grading people's language skills.
So we have TOEFL and TOEIC
and IELTS and Cambridge.
So there's another one,
Canadian Language Benchmarks.
There are 12 levels and each level
tries to describe in terms of, you
know, listening comprehension, reading
comprehension, speaking, and writing,
you know, what the person's level is.
Well, level one, theycan't do much.
So, you know, can hardly say anything.
Okay, that's level one.
Level two, can hardly say anything, but
can say a little more than level one.
In other words, all of the detailed
description of what this person is able
to do is relatively meaningless to me.
The person is gradually getting better,
hopefully, and there are no clear,
you know, demarcation lines between
level three and level four and five.
That's why beginner, intermediate
and advanced is pretty
good because it's simple.
It's a fluid thing.
It's not like there are steps like
this that we go through and we may be
progressing more quickly in comprehension,
not as quickly in speaking or writing,
or we may not even bother with writing.
And so trying to say that at each, you
know, benchmark level here is a clear
definition of what this person can do.
Now, the reason for this is that for
this Canadian Language Benchmark system,
they, they hope that, um, immigrants,
for example, can demonstrate the ability
to perform, uh, tasks related to being
a clerk, uh, you know, in a supermarket
or a receptionist at a hotel, uh,
jobs that are considered to be less
demanding when it comes to language.
You know, jobs that immigrants could
easily fill once they achieved that level.
Now of course, here again, uh, I
have, uh, met many checkout clerks
at supermarkets, many of whom are
immigrants, they all speak quite well.
I mean, the, the ones that are good
at it, they can actually entertain
conversations on different subjects.
I don't think it's that useful to try
to just train yourself on the limited
number of words you need for that.
A receptionist at a hotel even more.
So I think it's far better to focus
on improving your overall level in the
language, acquiring more words, doing
more listening and reading and not
pretending that just because you act
out certain roles or certain tasks that
that's going to prepare you for that task.
You're better to continue to
improve your comprehension through
lots of listening and reading.
And if you have that base,
even if when you start in a
particular job, you struggle.
If you have that comprehension,
you have the vocabulary you
will eventually improve.
And it really doesn't matter.
You know where you are, theoretically
in the sort of steps of the 12
language benchmarks, what matters is,
how do we get the, get the person?
How do we encourage that person?
How do we make it easier for that
person to continue to improve
and get better and better?
And I'm not sure that the sort of
Canadian Language Benchmark task-based
instruction is the way to go.
On the other hand, assigning yourself
tasks like doing a lot of listening
and reading and speaking is probably
going to get you there sooner.
So maybe a little bit controversial.
I'm sure I'll get some pushback
from professional language teachers.
Okay.
Thanks for listening.
Bye.